it's
appreciate you get dressed up here dude
Wow
bro you dress like Flint water because
they'd get too hungry
[Applause]
[Music]
right oh come come final come come final
copy write it right in there fine on
everybody I said warm nice that warm
what is that
did you got right there that's a purse
right there you knew that I was gonna
talk about it this guy wanted it look at
this let me see this give me that give
me that right now dude you better keep a
gun in the air bro that's though it's by
Hugo Boss is that the guy that's gonna
be stuffing your mouth full of dick
later and you said pressure you're not
sure thank you for saying that out loud
feel like that got us somewhere
who answers the question about coming in
a room of 600 people you just be quiet
right most people would do right
we should get to the Wellness
what's your name buddy Johnny how you
doing job you [ __ ] to be Johnny Johnny
Johnny what is your question
all right you know we're going to talk
about you know what is your [ __ ]
voice it [ __ ] son you know who
you sound like
you sound like Deary I'm like will you
blue facet like that be right all right
yeah we're gonna talk about I really
feel like we're about to say okay
Anderson we're on the scene right now
and it is going crazy down here in
Baltimore things are wild give us the
scoop all right Johnny talk to us for
although you know we're going to talk
about man stop man
you [ __ ] with us bro you got to be
[ __ ] with us man
half Portuguese Haitian and Trinidadian
okay which which one of you your
Trinidad that's what's up man I don't
know what a Trinidadian looks like at
all yeah can you point them out like you
can see them do beautiful people you're
good-looking dude and it's us up yeah
no you got it dude you look like common
with cancer
what's that sweetheart you're not smart
I don't think you're smart I don't think
you're smart if you were smart you would
know that's what's funny about the job
that's the exact thing that's funny
about the job and I think your math
brain isn't creative enough to
understand humor no no I'm being serious
well oh I'm being I don't think your
brain is made for humor it's not
everybody I'm sure you're really good at
engineering no you're really good at
engineering ruining other people's
nights that's fair and look there is a
place to go if you don't like humor is
no you shouldn't go to hell why would
you go to hell
that's for funny people you're not gonna
ruin our time in hell - how dare you
[ __ ] you're gonna follow me - [ __ ]
help it's not your [ __ ] minds I got a
deal with you here and in [ __ ] hell
oh how are you miss that because you
can't see me
[Applause]
I love southern into saying you are
looking at me and not the speaker so you
might be liable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of work
what's your back you're Asian right miss
what type of Asian your Taiwanese that's
a good one now that's a good one that's
like China 2.0 right Taiwanese right I'm
getting that right Taiwanese were like
[ __ ] if we doubt and then they were like
Japan's too far let's just stop right
here this islet this Islands good we're
not going all the way you're like those
Indians that made it to like Trinidad
you're the Indians like we're going to
America and then the first island are
like [ __ ] it pull over pull over this is
funny laugh I'm ready
black and white knew that [ __ ] pops is
black her mom is black pops a black mom
wait that's what's up hey you rarely see
the other one stepping up sisters catch
some white dick every once in a while
what the [ __ ] no we got good dick too
it's not as long but you know it stays
around
[Applause]
funny black guys dicks is so big they
can leave and still be in you that back
now I'll be back I'll be back you just
keep hold onto it
yeah you'll hold on to that one for a
little bit what I'll be right back I'm
going some smokes smokes together did
you just turn gay in the middle of your
sentence is it not a that the nine is
pistachio oh you are gay oh really
you must have came out the [ __ ] crying
barley get this off of me
oh why couldn't you just c-section me
[ __ ] oh that's disgusting
you're not gonna how old are you guys
just turn 18 si let me everybody stop
let me help you let me help you answer
that [ __ ] question again okay do not
ever say just turn to 18 again in your
life this guy's trying to get locked up
over here right if she's 18 you go 18 18
and legal don't be like just turned
you're not the [ __ ] brazzers title
that you just gave me for her Jesus
Christ jailbait you look like one
direction and you're about to go
directly to jail that's what he was
proud of that [ __ ] too wasn't he Steve
he's like just turned 18 yesterday fresh
as they come
now you guys aren't religious at all
your dad is but you didn't want you
found the area you're whacking off for
like 12 you're like I can't go back
Joseph Smith didn't have this [ __ ] right
here we had Pournami would have never
left New York I'll show you a Salt Lake
[Applause]
were you affected by it bro
yeah you who else was I looking at bro
you got an outfit on no this video y'all
can't see his outfit but you came ready
bro you bury somebody today what is this
do you drive a stagecoach in the 1800s
what is this chandelier you got on your
blazer stand up so everybody can see
I've never seen someone stand up and get
shorter that was the craze is that you
see that guy get off the seat and then
go down Punjabi
are you sick sick that's what's up
[ __ ] me six man those that do is wear
the turban is [ __ ] and they got that
bracelet that little silver bracelet
that's a badass bracelet nah for real
cuz back in the day that used to be a
sheath it would protect them from swords
because the six would a warrior class of
people in India and then over the years
you know the meaning has changed now is
used to rests on a steering wheel of
uber but